good afternoon everyone thank you very much for
having decided to attend this
session the purpose of my purpose for
today is to give you a
pragmatic introduction to the basic concepts of tensor
flow which as you know the platform
released by google for machine
learning is a  little introduction to
dip learning to do it what we will
build together is a system
capable of recognizing handwritten figures
with 99 percent accuracy we will
work with one of the classic databases
of machine learning and means which
contains 60 thousand images of
handwritten figures and  the figure they
represent before diving into deep
learning, however, let's start with
a somewhat simpler architecture the
database contains grayscale images
of dimensions 28 by 28 pixels
can therefore be transformed at the
top into a vector of size 784
whatever we want  have
handwritten numbers recognized is equivalent to
dividing images into 10 classes to
add  i love a layer of ten neurons
one for each digit what
exactly does a neuron do within a
neural network does three operations
the first is to calculate the
weighted sum of the inputs it receives the second
is so march a constant called threshold
the weighted sum plus the  threshold in
literature is called logic at the end
to produce its output the
neuron applies a non-linear
function called activation function
because non-linear essentially for
two reasons the non-linearity causes the
differences between different input vectors to
be amplified the second a lot
relevant for db learning is that the
non-linearity means that layers of neurons
can be stacked one on top of
the other as we will see later
which non-linear function because
objectively there are many in the
literature there is no general consensus
and it depends on the  problem when it comes
to classification the standard choice is
softmax what does the soft max do the soft
max takes p  For each neuron praise the
exponential calculation obtaining a
new vector with ten elements in
this case it calculates to the
vector norm and divides the exponential
this means that the output of the neurons can
be interpreted as a probability
the probability that the image  in
input you represent the figure associated
with the neuron let's formalize all
the concepts we have seen by working
instead of with a single image with
a group of 100 images in the lower
left
corner you see 100 images each transformed
into a vector and stacked one on top of
the other until  to form a hicks matrix
what you see here are the weights of
our 10 neurons that we put in a
matrix with 10 columns one per neuron
calculating the weighted sum
simply means doing what we were
taught in elementary school
multiplication in row by column and
we get to have  the weighted sum of the
first image for the first neuron
moving to the next column and then
to the third the fourth we can calculate
the weighted sums for all our
neurons for the first image
at this point we add the 10 thresholds
and we obtain the ten logics for the first
image
passing to the second image and
repeating the procedure of scanning
column by column of the matrix of the
weights we get the weighted sum for the
second image the third the fourth and
so on up to 100 at this point
we have to add to all these logic the
ten baileys 10 thresholds this operation
can be mathematically simple
written simply as a
multiplication of matrices to which it is
added  a vector adding the vector
requires to use a convention
called broadcast which
simply means that since the
ten-row matrix vector one we repeat it a
hundred times at this point we are ready
to apply our non-
linear function the soft max and obtain the
matrix of our  predictions for the
100 images let's
recap them all  then hicks is a
matrix that at 100 rows one for images
and 784 columns one per pixel w is the
weight matrix at 784 rows one per
pixel and 10 columns one per neuron b is
the vector of the thresholds at this point
we have to apply the soft max  to each
image and therefore to each row for the
matrix what false max takes
the exponential gets a new vector
of which it calculates the norm divides
the exponential and gives us an
output matrix that 100 rows one for each
image and 10 columns one  for each
neuron or equivalently one for each
digit
at this point
this mathematical formula is
the architecture of our first neural network
let's see how to implement it intense show
thanks to the fact that tensor flow
implements most of the
functions normally used
working with neural networks the thing  it is
quite fast
what we have not yet
discussed is what are the values of the weights and t
e values of the thresholds this is let's say the m
agic of  neural networks because
what we will do is simply
provide images of which we know
the represented figure and ask the
neural network to determine for us the
optimal weights and thresholds how we will do it we
will ask it to give us good
predictions in output what y how
we measure the goodness  of a prediction
here too the literature offers a wide
choice in the case of classification the
measure of the goodness of a prediction is
given by the entropy cross suppose we
have an image that represents a 6
this information can be
encoded in the vector y underscore
shown here whose elements  are all
zeroes except the one corresponding to the
digit 6 which equals 1 with this
notation the entropy cross of our
prediction y is defined simply
as minus the scalar product of y
underscore times the logarithm of y given the
definition of y underscore this
means that the  cross entropy is
simple equal simply equal to
minus
the logarithm of  the prediction of the
probability calculated by our
neural network that the image we know to
be a 6 is 6
because minus minus is simply because
the logarithm between 0 and 1 is a
negative source so in this way the
increasing here is a positive quantity
the  another useful property of the logarithm is
that an increasing monotone function
this means that the higher the
probability calculated by our
neural network that the
input image is a 6 the smaller the entropy cross is
therefore this provides us with a
strategy to determine  the weights and the
thresholds because what we will do is
show our neural network a
group of images
actively rieter with the images with
the figures they represent and we will
ask tensor flow to minimize
the cross entry by acting on the weights and the
thresholds let's see how it happens  basically
ok this demo is a bit slow to start
because the visualization is built and
mattes the clip
in case you decide to learn  re
seriously and third the flop I advise you
to use tensor board however for
pedagogical purposes
this is better in this panel at the
top right
you see the 100 digits we are supplying
in input to our neural network
those with the red background are the digits
for which the  class are the images excuses
if given that our neural network
has predicted a different figure from the one
actually represented
in the upper left panel
you see the accuracy of the neural network
which is nothing more than the percentage of
images for which the figure was
correctly identified if
you notice you will see that there are two lines a
blue line which for the training images
these 100 is a red line which
is actually calculated on 10 thousand images
that I have never shown to the
neural network these images are called
test images  what is the purpose
the purpose is essentially to check
that the neural network is not cheating by
storing the images that I provide them
cone during training but
instead you actually learn what
distinguishes a 3 down 4 and the diagrams
below left
are simply to check that
the training is proceeding
normally are the
weight distribution and the distribution of the thresholds
what needs to be checked  is that the
system does not get stuck at
a minimum of the entropy cross or and that
none of its weights and thresholds
begin to become infinite this of
agra this last panel shows the
accuracy of our neural network
on the 10 thousand test images here
you simply see a thousand  the first
are those for which the prediction is wrong
and they are in red so
you can see that in the course of
about 1000 training steps our
neural network has reached an
accuracy of 92 percent
dear friend back to the slide please
let's see now how  implement this
neural network and its
intense training flow the first operations to be carried
out intens  o flow are the
definition of variables and play
shoulders the variables are the degrees of
freedom of our system are those
quantities that we ask tenso float
to determine through
training the place
in this case is the weights matrix and
the vector  of the thresholds in square
brackets you can see the dimensions that
the family members should be the
placeholders instead are
input information that we must provide to our
neural network hicks is the placeholder for
the images read from the database
if we look at its dimensions are
four
do not be frightened by the term
tensor  it is simply a matrix
that instead of having two indices knows more than
the first does not simply tell us that
we do not define at this moment how
many images we want to read this
allows us to
manage the
training phase and the testing phase 28 and 28 at the same time
as you will remember it is the size
of the database image which has 28
pixels p  er 28 pixels 1
simply means that the image is in shades
of gray had it been rgb colors here
we would have had a 3 at this point
we have everything we need to
define the architecture of our
neural network this line this
instruction is exactly what
we first saw the operation
say shape module which does nothing but
reorder the elements in the
holder hicks price so that each row
represents an image
the other placeholder we
need in the training phase is the one
that contains the information of which
figures the images contain y
underscore at this point we can
evaluate the goodness of the predictions
made by our oral le network by means of
the cross within fi which is simply
minus the scalar product between y
underscore and the logarithm of y
these two instructions are the heart of
our  program ten only the first
selects which excellent exercise we want to
use among those available
intense flow in quest  o case we will take
the descendant grading the second asks
the heiser team to minimize the
increasing robin by acting on the variables
of our system then the weights and the
thresholds in practice this as happens
tensor flow in the
multidimensional space of weights and
thresholds calculates the gradient of the cross
entropy the gradient is a vector that
points in the direction of maximum
growth of the cross entropy in this
multidimensional space
if we therefore subtract a little of the gradient
from the current values of the weights and thres
olds the center acre decreases there a little is es
ablished by this parameter lean
n  great which says how much portion of the
gradient we have to subtract because
this subtlety is due to the fact
that the gradient being a vector
also has an intensity and what we would like to
avoid is the situation where the system
close to the minimum of the entropy cross
starts hopping around
because the  gradient is too large
the last piece of our sv code  and
another third feature of the flow
which is the deferred execution all the
instructions we have seen so far
do not produce numerical results what
they produce is a graph in memory
whose nodes are the operations and whose
connections are the interdependencies between
di  them because this choice
essentially for two reasons the first is
that knowing this graph allows the
third flow to calculate the gradient
of each operation exactly
the second is because knowing this
graph allows to optimize
the execution of code thanks for flow
in environments  distributed and as you will understand
this is a considerable advantage in
practice this means that
to obtain the numerical values it is neces
ary to define a tense flow sessi
n and then call invoke the run m
thod on the operation we want to perfo
m providing at the same time the value
that  we want to use instead
of placeholders this is done
using the feed argument of i  ct what
matters is that it takes as input a
dictionary whose keys are the pay
solders to be replaced and whose values
e tensors to be used you will
emember that trend step is the step in which
we ask the minimal optimizer to minim
ze the entropy cross to calcu
ate the cross  tropez we need to
know which digits correspond to the
images we are reading for in addition
to calculate the entropy cross we
need calculation sap to have the
prediction of our neural networks
so we need the images
so we need to provide the
milk images from the database all this
to  tell you that our
training phase consists of a four cycle in
which we will read from the database 100 images
and the figures they represent, we will create a
dictionary with the keys hicks and y
underscore and we will invoke the run method
on the training operation,
summarizing this for the last time
is the code that allows us to create
our first neural network and all  enarla
first operation define variables and
placeholder variables are degrees of
freedom the placeholders are the
input information that we must
provide to our neural network second
operation the definition
of the architecture of our
neural network third operation definition
of the cross entropy fourth operation
definition of what  of the strategy
to train our neural network
last training cycle with
this program
about our problem
we have reached an accuracy of 92
percent is a lot or a little
according to you in this case
you already know that it is not much because I have
probably told you if  I didn't do it I was
wrong that our goal is to reach
99 percent in general the answer
to this question however depends on the
application for which you are
developing your neural network and the
accuracy of the method you are
currently using does not  there is an
absolute value 50 percent can be
very little  depending on what you are
currently doing what can we
do to improve this 92 percent
as the session title suggests
we can go from a single layer to
multiple layers in this case we have 5 layers
of neurons with respective 5 the air of
neurons with  respectively 200 160 30 and
10 neurons the neurons of the first layer
exactly as it happened before
take the image as input they
calculate the weighted sum add
their thresholds and apply their
activation function the neurons of the second
layer take the put of the first layer
calculate  the weighted sum
apply their thresholds apply their
activation function the same for the
third the second and excuse the third the
fourth and the fifth these layers as well
as for the number of neurons
also differ in the
activation function used for the last
layer we continue to use the
software
because the problem we want to
solve is always to
categorize the images  agini for the
intermediate layers we use a function
called relu which stands for rec you
make linear united this function is
defined as identically null on the
negative reals such as the surreal identities
positives and zero because we use the rev
the pragmatic answer is because it works
then c  'it is an academic response which is
that according to which compared to
historically more used functions
such as sigma ideas the
hyperbolic tangent use the luminous area
the problem of evanescent gradients and
allows to train networks with multiple layers
let's see how to implement this
intense neural network  flow exactly as it
happened before
the first operation to do is to define
for each layer a pair a hub of a
pair which is given by the weights of the vectors
and their thresholds with respect to before
note that the weights of the nos of our
layers in this case are initialized
sampling the values from a trunc
ted Gaussian distribution then witho
t the tails and this is the deviation  standard
what is the reason for this operation
simply break the symmetry
so that our heiser team
starts from a point in the space that
allows them to find the minimum more easily
at this point we
simply have to stack iva lei player
this is done in this way the  pri
the second instruction is exactly
that of the first hicks architecture I
remember that it is the sensor that contains the
images
at this point the output of the first layer
is used as the input of the second and
so on until the last one also in this
case I think the flow implements  already the
real function and therefore we do not have to
do much with this new neural network
we say able to reach
an accuracy of 98%
if we look at the curves with a little more
attention
we see that both on the test
images and on the images of  training the
curves are very noisy this is
a general indication that the
training phase has gone too fast
in the sense that the system
actually started hopping around the
minimum of the entry cross without
reaching
it the trick to solve this
problem is to insert an
exponential decay for the learning rates
sorry what it
simply means that we start as fast as
before and more and more we get closer  at
least among the most we slow down
accuracy again 98 per cent
much more regular curves even we
reach 100 per cent on the
training images
what becomes apparent is that
at a certain point the minimization of the
entropy cross on the
training images occurs at the expense of the
goodness of the predictions on the test images
this in itself is not an
unexpected thing because the system is blind
to the test images what it
means however is that the neural network
instead of learning to distinguish the
figures is learning to recognize the
images we provide  in input
this phenomenon has a name
you have c  called over fitting and we have
also studied a lot so there are
many solutions
the solution is to reduce the
degrees of freedom available to
the neural network in this way it no longer has
space to memorize and must relearn
must start learning the
regulated re-normalization technique
of  regularization sorry most in vogue
is the so-called trop out it is very
simple
at each cycle
to an interaction of the
training cycle what happens is that
each neuron dies with a certain
probability this
necessarily forces the other neurons to
become more intelligent because they no
longer know  who will tell them what and to whom they
will tell what implementing the drop out
as you see the network can no longer
store the training images and
we have maintained an accuracy of 98
percent by
quickly summarizing our
first experiences with deep learning
we have seen that with five  layers a
fixed learning reit we
reached an accuracy  of 98 per
cent on the test images but with
very noisy curves and therefore the system
did not reach the minimum of the
entropy cross we added an
exponential decay for the running
lights and this
certainly improved the situation compared to
reaching the minimum at the expense
of the  ability to generalize
our neural network
at this point we have
therefore introduced the degrees of freedom of
our system and with the drop out and
this has started to learn
again, however, we are still very far from the 99
percent that we want to reach
at this point in a  normal project in
which the answer is not already known
the options to be evaluated are
essentially three decrease the number
of neurons because we have already decreased
the number of freedom competition so
maybe remove her I was remove the
number of layers acknowledge that our
database does not contain  enough
information to reach 99
percent or render  realizes that
the architecture we have chosen
is not exploiting all the information
contained in the database in this case
we know
that the answer is the third because if you
think about it what distinguishes one
digit from another are the
spatial relationships between the signs  that we draw in
on the paper and
we have absolutely not
used this spatial information the solution to do it is to
resort to a tip to a specific layer
called with v.le shaun to the layer
imagine that this is our
image now in color so you have the
three rgb channels what happens in
this network is that the neuron in a live
in this layer and that the non-
layer neuron simply sees a portion
of the image above its neighbor
sees a portion a little more to the right the
neighbor of the neighbor ideas and  so on all
the other neurons
the peculiarity is that however all the
neurons share the same weights
so all this this group of
neurons that I will call canal  and it actually
just has 48 degrees of freedom 48 is
simply the fact that our
portion is wide 4 high 4 and deep 3
obviously reducing
degrees of freedom so drastically is not feasible because
if you think about it a second our first
neural network had about  8 thousand degrees of
freedom to compensate for this drastic
reduction what you do and add
more channels in this case and I
simply added a second to
make you understand the weights of these two channels
can be subscribed easily
as a four-dimensional tensor where
the first two  dimensions give the first
two dimensions give the size of the
portion of the image seen in this
case 4x4 the third gives the number of
input channels in this case 3 because the
color images and two give the number of
output channels
in this case two this  it is a common
shaun at the layer what you then have to
deal with building a
convention network at the layer is how to move from
this dimension  sion to a smaller dimension
because in the end the problem that
we want to solve in practice is
to classify 10 neurons to do so
there are essentially two strategies
the first is to introduce another
specific type of layer called pooling
layer the one that originates from this
layer  from the empirical observation
that during the training phase each
channel of the hong kong rational layer
specializes in recognizing a
particular shape where by shape I mean
vertical lines horizontal
lines oblique lines and so on
so most neurons
normally do not see anything
exist only  few neurons that
actually see something to
reduce the size then the
strategy and consider groups of
four neurons and pass it to the
next the maximum value of these
four neurons these are the pooling
layers the other strategy that
we will use is simply to play
with the pace of our scan that
what does it mean do you remember the first
neuron that saw the portion of the
image its neighbor instead of seeing
the image the same portion of magic is
shifted by one pixel it moves by two
obviously this causes the
output size to be in width
and  in height is the half of the car
of the input ones because we move
by two now we have all the
ingredients to build our
first common shaun to the network
this is the architecture we are going to
build the first 3 layers
are the convol and shaun  hall layers the
last two are traditional layers like
those we have seen so far
the input image is a tensor 28 x
28 x 1 because you remember that we are
in grayscale which in this case the weights
of the first convention to the layer that
we use tell us that each neuron
sees a portion of the image wide 5
high 5 to only one input output layer
sorry and puts 4 output layers
and uses a step equal to 1 so the
dimensions  sions of the output are 28 x 28 x 4
the second layer instead common shaun to
layer a as weights w2 in this case the
portion of the image that reads at
width 4 height 44 input channels
which are the outputs of the previous one
and 8 of output  however it uses step 2
this means that the dimension 14
that half of 28 14 and 8
the last with duration at layer a as
weights between with v3 again use sees a
portion of 4x4 image reads 8
input channels and 12 output channels  the
step and two again and then from 14 you
go to 7 7 and 12
at this point the you have a layer
of that of the old type what
this layer does it simply attaches to
all the neurons present in the convention
at the previous layer which are  7x7 by 12
the last layer is the layer that we have
always had so 10 neurons
soft max activation functions is that it
provides us with the probabilities for the
figures for our ten digits
as output let's see how to implement this
architecture certainly more  more complex
its intense the pattern is always the
same first the variables for the various
layers and then the architecture in reality
what you see is that the only
difference is that instead of defining
matri we define ourselves as tensors, you
will remember that the app weights  of the
first con volition to her were 5 x 5 1
which is the fact that the image was
in grayscale and the output was 4 ok
so all very simple
this is the code that defines
the architecture in this case again
I think  flow implements a function
that simplifies our life in fact com2 of
what it does is exactly by means of a
double cycle to scan
the tensor that is provided in
input using the second argument
as weight and taking the steps as argument
then with this instruction  y1 and the
output of the first with v.le shaun to the layer
the stack taking of the various layers works
exactly as before
the output of the first layer is the input of the
second and so on
the only thing to pay attention  it is the
fact that the fourth layer was a
traditional layer and therefore before passing
the car of the third layer to the fourth player it
is necessary to
transform transform it into a vector with this
architecture
we managed to reach 99 point
1 percent
but you see that  the network exhibits over
feat we have given it too much degrees of
freedom
but we know what is the strategy to
solve this problem
use a rule to use
regularization instead of doing
it directly I will show you the one that
has a standard methodology in
neural networks in case the  your system
exhibits regularization or for rents
to find what is the
optimal size what you do and increase the
number of freedom gray [ __ ] on
one side and add
regularization on the other side because
in this way you can find what
is  the correct balance between the two
in this case if you see the portions of
images read by the various communities  ne shaun to the
layer are larger they have more output and
therefore there are greater freedoms
but we apply the drop out to the fourth
layer because only to the fourth layer because
if you take into account where
degrees of freedom are distributed you will see that
this layer weighs much more  of all
the others
with this device I realize
that we have run a lot
we have reached 99.3 percent and
we have solved the problem of over
fitting
if this session has
aroused your intense interest the flow and
in deep learning I advise you to
check the  works of my colleague
martin this session is essentially
an extract of his namesake that he
held at next and above all there is
also a cod lab where you can go and
do and redo exactly what
we did and even more
the last question to  I want to
answer is because google has decided to
develop a machine
learning platform or a new
machine learning platform  The two fundamental aspects in
my opinion are those that none
of the solutions on the market
guaranteed the possibility of solving
complicated problems such as those
that google face to solve them and
then quickly scale the solution into
production the
tensor flow adoption curve inside  of google
shows that I think it is capable of doing it
the other fundamental point is
the heterogeneity of the hardware on which
currently a machine
learning platform must operate
and also in this case tensor flow has
solved great big problems
by easily passing from c più to gpu  to
mobile phones up to the third to the eternal
soulfly united obviously tensor flow is
completely integrated in the
google cloud platform solutions and can be
exploited in three ways, let's say
the first is two unfinished self tours
ngeny the second is through a
full service the manager where the  all
you have to worry about is writing the
ton code on the flop and then i  The passage
into production is a click away
as you have heard many times is the
third mode is that plot
pre-trained models available via pd
which this is a list
said that thank you for
your attention and I wish you a good
evening
[Applause]